et la déforestation continue d'augmenter
dans les régions tropicales de
l'amazonie environ 38 mille mètres
carrés 4 kilomètres carrés de forêts
primaires ont été détruites l'an dernier
soit l'équivalent de la superficie de la
suisse des chiffres communiqués par
lohan ga global forest watch le tiers de
ses pertes a eu lieu au brésil
les ong redoutent également un projet de
loi sur la régularisation des
exploitations illégales de terres
appartenant à des peuples autochtones ou
au domaine public et ce alors que les
normes environnementales et les droits
fonciers des peuples autochtones sont
parfois remis en cause par le nouveau
gouvernement
on parle justement avec ali second si
elle est responsable communication et
développement chez coeur de frais madame
gonthier bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
alors il ya une occupation au
désordonnée des terrains six cent mille
kilomètres carrés environ donc presque
la france
en quoi ce projet va-t-il avoir des
conséquences sur la déforestation
amazonienne
alors le projet en fait les risques
autour de la matière de la légalisation
de l'utilisation des terres qui étaient
des terres donc public et qui sont
utilisés par différents niveaux de
population en fait ça peut être des
agriculteurs sur des surfaces et moyenne
jusqu'à de l'avoir industrie donc là les
foules les images qu'on voit c'est
plutôt de là on va dire de la
déforestation issu d'un modèle agricole
intensif ou des étapes de dégradation de
la forêt qui vont d'abord être une
récolte du bois pour pour être vendus
alors c'est du bois qui peut se
retrouver ensuite de manière illégale
dans les chaînes d'approvisionnement
pour tout un tas de produits et au fil
de la dégradation de ses forêts ensuite
on a une étape souvent de défrichage par
le feu qui peut amener aux incendies
catastrophique qu'on a vu l'année
dernière mais qui qui se répète quand
même tout les trucs les plus chaque
année et le stade final c'est du coup la
destruction totale de cette parcelle de
forêt l installation de culture
le risque avec du coup on va dire table
rase sur l'utilisation illégale de
certaines parcelles
c'est que on a des conflits sociaux très
importants entre les populations
autochtones qui eux habitent dans la
forêt depuis des centaines d'années et
gère les ressources forestières de
manière tout à fait durable on a pas de
phénomène de dégradation des forêts dans
les zones on a des populations
autochtones qui gèrent leur écosystème
et qui prélèvent juste ce dont ils ont
besoin
c'est vraiment depuis les années 80 où
le gouvernement a autorisé en fait
l'installation des agriculteurs y en a
des conflits sociaux on a dépensé des
atteintes graves à l'environnement qui
augmente énormément ces dernières années
sans compter voilà les conséquences au
niveau climatique et environnementale au
niveau international alors au premier
trimestre 2001 la déforestation en
amazonie a augmenté de 51% par rapport à
l'année dernière en plus de la moitié
c'est un surfer quand même très
effrayant oui tout à fait l'année
dernière on était sur 24 millions
d'hectares de forêts par de couvert
forestier perdu dans le monde donc là on
a du coup des perspectives qui pour
cette année sont très inquiétantes alors
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
faites pour accompagner les populations
autochtones vers un développement
durable
alors au niveau des populations
autochtones la principale problématique
c'est la conservation leurs droits sur
sur les terres donc oui il ya énormément
d'initiatives d'associations de
populations autochtones et locales mais
qui sont en conflit avec le gouvernement
et est avec les agriculteurs et les
industries sur place au niveau plus
mondial qu'on constate c'est que les
causes de la déforestation elles sont
les mêmes partout
c'est dû à la conversion des terres
forestières en terres agricoles et là
dedans on va avoir 40 % qui sont dus à
l'agriculture commerciale donc plus à
destination des exportations au brésil
par exemple on est pratiquement que sur
des causes dus à l'agriculture du soja
et à l'élevage bovin le soja s'est
cultivé pour ensuite alors soit utilisée
directement la brésil soit à
l'exportation énormément apporté par
l'europe pour nourrir le bétail
principalement les porcins et la
volaille du coup pour répondre à ces
problématiques de déforestation de
l'agriculture commerciale
il faut travailler plus haut niveau
politique internationale au niveau des
chaînes d'approvisionnement aussi des
entreprises parce qu'il part emploi
emploi énorme dans quel produit est ce
que il accepte de commercialiser et
d'importer la deuxième cause de
déforestation liée à l'agriculture
et là il ya vraiment c'est quelque chose
qu'on
on sait assez peu c'est 30 % qui sont
dus en fait à l'agriculture de
subsistance
donc c'est la petite agriculture que les
gens pratiquent pour pour subvenir à
leurs besoins à l'alimentation et au
pour générer des revenus vraiment à
l'échelle familiale
ça c'est plusieurs millions de personnes
sur la planète qui dépendent de 6
millions de personnes milliards de
personnes parlant donc c'est vraiment
très important de personnes qui
dépendent au quotidien des rongeurs et
des ressources de la forêt comment
est-ce qu'on accompagne les petits
producteurs finalement vers des méthodes
alternatives basse et des projets de
développement en fait aller s'est désolé
je vais devoir vous vous coupez on est
en plein direct et ça y est c'est de la
france ce journal je suis désolé encore
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir été en direct sur herbe